o
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist ein thema auf den auf einer art
niemand gewartet hat weil es ja die
aufnahmen aus montreal zum beispiel von
queen gibt und die sind so dass man zum
beispiel auf anguckt muss man danach
nichts mehr von oder über queen oder
überhaupt irgendwas angucken sondern das
einfach so oft bis man stirbt weil das
so schön ist aber auch wenn jemand
darauf gewartet hat ist eine willkommene
ergänzung dazu weil man das ja nicht die
ganze zeit gucken kann beim menschen
überwältigt ist also gut man was ein
bisschen paar level darunter was
trotzdem super schönes und das wäre dann
der film
[Musik]
dem film fehlt natürlich auch was
nämlich die wahrheit zum beispiel aber
mal ganz im ernst es gibt wikipedia
es gibt tausend biografie das ding ist
ein musical oder so was ähnliches
moderne oper oder musical oder sowas
ähnlich und jetzt was der stelle
wechseln werden den opernhaften teil der
opernhafte teil klar dieser fink weiss
gar nicht so genau was er erzählt weil
er versucht das leben von für die merkel
zu erzählen das ist nicht erzielbar weil
ja alles mögliche durcheinander kreuz
und quer gelaufen ist er war unter
anderem schwul und seine große liebe war
wie uns der film sagte ein paar
biografien die ich gelesen habe war
trotzdem eine frau oder deswegen oder
warum auch immer
ich liebe es geschafft überlegst ganze
raum gehört dir
[Musik]
die nicht zu sein das schöne daran ist
natürlich dass solche geschichten
deswegen war sind selbst wenn alles
gelogen ist in diesem film ist fast das
meiste gelogen weil es natürlich auch so
sachen auf eine ganz andere art ankommt
als man glaubt nämlich es geht erstens
natürlich darum wen man liebt und nicht
darum dass männer frauen oder wombat
sind andererseits aber schon darum dass
einem keiner vorschreiben kann das noch
irgend was nicht sein darf und wenn man
schwul sein will dann ist man eben
schwul und wenn man schwul ist will man
auch schwul sein und solche sachen also
wahnsinnig kompliziertes thema mit sehr
guten gesicht die schauspieler sehen
alle aus wie sie aussehen müssen nämlich
wie die mitglieder der gruppe queen
nur der beamer legden freddie mercury
spielt er sieht noch ein bisschen mehr
aus wie die gruppe queen und noch wie
freddie mercury
also ist sieht aus wie die ganze gruppe
unter dem akku das heißt also den jungen
vergeben natürlich spielt da ein
bisschen älter aus als wirklicher freund
als er den reifen freddie mercury spielt
ein bisschen jünger aus aber das ist so
ein wie soll man sagen
sicherheitsabstand der so ein bisschen
ausdruck das ist jetzt nicht nur
varieté-show ist mit dem ik tor oder ein
kindergeburtstag sondern eine ernsthafte
interpretation einer großen
persönlichkeit die es mal gegeben hat
und die deswegen so groß weil sie ein
unglaublich großes maul hatte ein riesen
angeber war und der trick bei der
angeberei war manchmal ist angeberei was
gut ist wenn man nämlich sagt ich bin
super gut und das dann als stachel und
aufforderungen nimmt tatsächlich
supergut werden zu müssen
dann kommt so was raus die bei freddie
mercury oder wie bei rami malek als
[Musik]
bereits noch mal wieviele galileo trägst
du nach in dieser band ist nur platz für
eine drama queen klare ja eigentlich
würde ich sagen nur queen fans sollten
sich den film anschauen aber ich würde
auch sagen alle leute sollten queen fans
sein das heißt ich habe ein bisschen
problem wenn ich beantworten sollte er
den angucken soll gucken halt an du bist
eine legende
wir sind alle agenten
[Applaus]